China has admitted that a suspected spy
balloon which has entered U.S airspace
is theirs but says it is a civilian
Airship which is conducting
meteorological and other scientific
research American officials say they're
tracking the balloon which has been over
the U.S for a couple of days now fighter
jets have been put on standby but the
White House has decided not to shoot it
down for now let's get more on this from
our defense and security analyst
Professor Michael Clark who's in the
studio with me um Michael good to see
you again good afternoon
where exactly is this balloon and I say
balloon but it's rather large isn't it
yes um everything is measured
International comparative measurements
are either London buses Wembley or Wales
and this is three London buses uh so
it's big
um and it's got it can it carries
several uh kilos of surveillance
equipment we assume and it has traveled
over the Aleutian Islands uh and it's
hovering over Montana and the reason
that Montana is important a lot of these
northern states are important because
that's where the American missile bases
are they're intercontinental ballistic
missiles they're Minuteman three the the
important missiles are in the north of
the country because the shortest
distance between America and Russia is
over the North Pole that's why they're
in the north and although no nobody
lives there are very few people live in
this part of the United States very
underpopulated this is a very sensitive
area and the red areas that we've marked
on the map there those are the areas
where the satellite bases to launch the
missiles are cited and so every every
base so the Maelstrom base so the
billing space has 50 missiles and those
missiles are in groups of ten so there
are five launch control points connected
to every base and that the red area
shows you the distribution of the launch
control points they're quite well spread
out for obvious reasons
and this this balloon has been hovering
over them for some time and it's really
upset the Americans I mean you know the
balloon is that we guess something above
60 000 feet aircraft get to about 40 000
feet they could try rockets at it but
the point about the balloons is that
they go above the level that aircraft
can fly at effectively so the fighter
jets exactly yeah so they occupy that
space between the ceiling for aircraft
and satellites and so they're into the
stratosphere and these balloons can just
hang around for a long time
um surveilling and listening and
collecting information
what is this about Michael why have the
Chinese put up a balloon over the U.S
whatever it is doing scientific research
or what is it about they wanted it to be
seen
um it's clear we we we've tracked it
um this is based on the sky weather
um using the NOAA um model which is the
oceanic and aeronautical uh agency and
this is at forty thousand feet which is
a bit low but if you look at the winds
at 40 000 feet that's where the bloom
would have come from from China across
the Aleutian Islands across Alaska and
into the United States we put another
model onto it at about 60 000 feet which
is more of the operational height it'll
be at but that gives it a slightly
different track but it still ends up
over Montana so
um that's where we we think the balloon
has come from so why are the Chinese
doing this they want it to be seen they
want it to be noticed and my view is
that this is all about the Philippines
um this is about the nine dash line
there's there's a famous nine-dash line
the Chinese Drew this line they put nine
dashes on it and they said all of that
line belongs to us everything inside
that area is Chinese territory and
they're building illegal bases in the
spratly islands and the Paracel Islands
military bases that they've got no right
to they've been found the international
court has found against them they've
just ignored it and of course the
Philippines is most affected by that
because it's their territorial Waters
plus Malaysia and Vietnam as well now
the Philippi the Americans this week
have said we're going back to the
Philippines they're opening four
American new American military bases so
for the first time in years the American
Military is going back to the
Philippines and Lloyd Austin is on a
tour of East Asia it's all been
announced it was in the wind before but
it's now confirmed the Chinese never let
anything like this go by without making
their own gesture without some sort of
retaliation and I'm fairly sure that
it's the four new bases military based
in the Philippines that are driving
China say okay if you want a competition
we'll we'll have a competition how do
you like this and so they're making it
very clear that they're taking a big
interest now in collecting Intelligence
on American missile bases okay Professor
Clark thank you so much